STEVE: IT IS 8:31 ON THE EAST
COAST AND WE HAVE A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
THE MARCH JOBS REPORT IS OUT AND
IT IS NOT GOOD.
IT SHOWS 701,000 JOBS WERE LOST,
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS AT 4.4%
AINSLEY: THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
LET’S BRING IN STUART VARNEY
HOST OF VARNEY & COMPANY ON FOX
BUSINESS NETWORK.
STUART WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO
THIS?
STUART: OKAY LET ME REPEAT THOSE
NUMBERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
INDEED PRETTY BAD.
WE LOST 701,000 JOBS IN THE
MONTH OF MARCH AND THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WENT UP TO
4.4%.
NOW THAT’S BAD, BUT IT DOESN’T
REALLY PAINT A TRUE PICTURE OF
THE EMPLOYMENT MARKET AS WE
SPEAK.
THIS SURVEY WEAK FOR THE MARCH
JOBS REPORT WAS EARLY IN THE
MONTH OF MARCH SO IT DIDN’T
REALLY CAPTURE THE FULL IMPACT
OF THE VIRUS ON OUR ECONOMY, SO
YOU CAN EXPECT LATER IN APRIL,
THESE JOBLESS NUMBERS WILL GO
WAY UP.
PERHAPS A BETTER INDICATOR OF
THE TRUE STATE OF EMPLOYMENT IS
THE FACT THAT 10 MILLION PEOPLE
APPLIED FOR JOBLESS BENEFITS,
JUST IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS, AND
I MIGHT ADD, THAT MARIA, WAS
JUST TOLD BY A FED GOVERNOR,
MARIA BARTIROMO ON FOX BUSINESS,
THAT THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE NOW
IS ACTUALLY CLOSER TO 10%
ALREADY, AND BY THE WAY, WE’VE
GOT A BIG INVESTMENT FIRM, MSNBC
SUGGESTING THAT THE ECONOMY,
WHICH WE NOW SAY WILL SHRINK BY
38%, NOW THAT IS DIRE, INDEED.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, STUART, WHAT IS
DIRE AS WELL, IS WHEN THE NEXT
NUMBER COMES OUT, KEEP IN MIND,
WHEN THE PRESIDENT ORDERED
PEOPLE TO STAY AT HOME,
CURRENTLY THERE ARE, AND VARIOUS
GOVERNORS HAVE AS WELL,
CURRENTLY THERE ARE STAY AT HOME
ORDERS IN STATES THAT ACCOUNT
FOR 82% OF OUR GDP.
IF YOU GOT 82% OF THE GDP,
PEOPLE NOT GOING TO WORK, THAT’S
GOING TO BE UGLY.
STUART: OH, YOU CAN SEE THIS.
I MEAN, WE’VE GOT AT TSA CHECK
POINTS AT AIRPORTS,
2 MILLION FEWER PASSENGERS ARE
BEING PROCESSED EVERY DAY THAN
ONE YEAR AGO.
THE FLIGHTS THAT TAKE OFF ARE
ESSENTIALLY EMPTY.
RIDERSHIP ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IS DOWN 75%
BECAUSE IF PEOPLE AREN’T GOING
TO WORK THEY’RE NOT COMMUTING.
TRAFFIC HAS EVEN EASED UP
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THAT’S EXTRAORDINARY.
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY, YOU
STOPPED PEOPLE GOING TO WORK SO
THE ECONOMY IS AT A DEAD STOP
AND AS MORGAN STANLEY SUGGESTS
IT’S ACTUALLY SHRINKING.
WE’VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS BEFORE AND WE WON’T GET
OVER IT UNTIL SUCH TIME AS
THOSE STAY AT HOME ORDERS
BEGIN TO BE RELAXED.
AT THAT POINT, YOU MIGHT SEE
THINGS IMPROVE, BUT NOT
UNTIL THEN.
BRIAN:  SO STUART IN 2008 THESE
NUMBERS WERE INTRIGUING BECAUSE
WE WANTED TO FIND OUT HOW THE
BANKING SYSTEM WOULD REPAIR
ITSELF, HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE
EFFECTED AND HOW TO FIX IT WITH
TARP.
NOW THESE ARE NOT INTRIGUING,
THIS IS A SELF-INFLICTED WOUND
AND A SLOW MOTION CAR WRECK THAT
WE BROUGHT ON OURSELVES BECAUSE
WE’VE BEEN TOLD THIS IS THE ONLY
WAY TO DO IT.
WE SHOULD REVERSE IT AND TALK
ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
WORKING BECAUSE THE NUMBER WILL
GET TERRIBLE AND THIS IS ONLY
GOING TO REINFORCE WHAT WAS
DEMANDED BY OUR GOVERNMENT AND
THE WORLD BODY THAT WE STOP
WORKING, STOP TALKING TO EACH
OTHER, STOP BEING PRODUCTIVE,
STOP GOING TO GYM, STOP GOING
OUT TO DINNER, SO TO ME, I’M
EVEN SURPRISED I’D RATHER FIND
OUT THE 20% STILL ON THEIR JOBS
HOW LICK LUCKY WE ARE TO BE
DOING THIS.
WE’RE AN  ANOMALY NOW.
STUART: THAT MAKES A FAIR POINT
BRIAN BUT YOU CAN’T SUGAR COAT
EXACTLY WHERE WE ARE.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS ORDERED SHUT
DOWN OF THE ECONOMY, ON
MEDICAL GROUNDS AND THERE WILL
BE AN ENORMOUS POLITICAL BATTLE
WHEN WE START TO SEE THAT CURVE
BENDING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS THERE WILL BE
A POLITICAL BATTLE AS TO HOW
SOON, WE RELAX THESE STAY AT
HOME ORDERS.
THAT’LL BE A MONUMENTAL BATTLE
BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT
THE ECONOMY AND THE DAMAGE BEING
DONE TO THE ECONOMY WILL WANT TO
OPEN IT AGAIN AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
ON THE OTHER SIDE YOU’LL HAVE
PEOPLE WHO SAY LOOK YOU OPEN UP
THE ECONOMY, YOU OPEN UP THE
STAY AT HOME RULES TOO SOON
AND YOU’LL HAVE A SECOND WAVE OF
THE VIRUS GO THROUGH WITH EVEN
MORE DAMAGE.
THERE’S A POLITICAL BATTLE
COMING.
IT’S BASED ON THE STATE OF THE
ECONOMY, WHICH AT THIS POINT
, BRIAN, IS DIRE.
FLAT OUT, ON ITS BACK, DIRE
SITUATION.
AINSLEY: STUART WE LOOK AT THAT
NUMBER AND IT’S SAD BUT DOES
THAT INCLUDE THE PEOPLE IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY LET’S
SAY WHO WERE LAID OFF BUT
THEY’RE GOING TO GET THEIR JOBS
BACK AND THROUGH THIS STIMULUS
MONEY, THE RESTAURANT OWNERS
AREN’T GOING TO HAVE TO PAY THAT
MONEY IT’S COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
STUART: OKAY LET’S BE CLEAR.
THE MONEY THAT’S STARTING TO GO
OUT TODAY, THIS $2.2 TRILLION,
THAT IS NOT STIMULUS.
THAT IS RESCUE.
THAT’S MONEY GOING TO THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN LAID OFF, OR  OUT
OF WORK, THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN.
IT’S MONEY GOING TO THEIR
PAYCHECKS.
IT’S CALLED A PAYCHECK
PROTECTION THING, AND SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN GO TO THEIR BANKS
AS OF TODAY, AND GET A LOAN,
WHICH TRANSFERS INTO A GRANT IF
THEY DON’T LAY PEOPLE OFF.
SO THE MONEY IS BEING PUSHED OUT
THERE NOW, BUT DON’T GET THE
IDEA THAT SOMEHOW OR
OTHER THIS STIMULATES THE
ECONOMY.
IT DOESN’T.
IT RESCUES MILLIONS OF
INDIVIDUALS.
THE STIMULUS COMES LATER, WHEN
WE START TO RELAX THE STAY AT
HOME RULES AND THE ECONOMY CAN
EXPAND.
THAT’S WHEN YOU NEED THE
STIMULUS.
THAT’S WHEN IT KICKS IN.
STEVE: I LIKE THE WAY THAT YOU
PUT IT, THAT IT IS A RESCUE
PACKAGE TO RESCUE THE BUSINESSES
, AND FOR  ALL OF
THE AMERICANS, STUART AS WELL,
WHO WERE SIMPLY DOING WHAT DR.
FAUCI TOLD US IN ABOUT 35
MINUTES AGO AND THAT IS THE ONLY
WAY AT THIS STAGE BEFORE THERE
IS A VACCINE THAT WE ARE
UNCERTAIN ABOUT TREATMENTS THE
ONLY WAY TO TURN THAT CORNER
ON THIS DEADLY THING IS TO STAY
AT HOME, AND THAT’S WHY GOVERNOR
S AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE MOBILIZED TO NOT
ONLY ORDER PEOPLE TO STAY IN
PLACE, BUT ALSO THEY’VE GOT THIS
RESCUE BILL, AND TODAY, IS
THE DAY THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
OFFICIALLY CAN START APPLYING
AND PROVIDED THEY KEEP THE
PEOPLE ON THE BOOKS WHICH IS
GOING TO HELP THE PEOPLE WHO
THEY HAVE FURLOUGHED THEY MAY
NOT HAVE TO, THEY WILL NOT HAVE
TO REPAY THOSE LOANS.
STUART: THAT’S TRUE.
THEY BECOME A GRANT.
IF YOU TAKE THIS GOVERNMENT
MONEY AND YOU DON’T LAY PEOPLE
OFF, IF YOU DO THAT, YOU DON’T
LAY PEOPLE OFF, THEN IT’S NOT A
LOAN WHICH HAS TO BE REPAID.
IT’S A GRANT, WHICH DOESN’T HAVE
TO BE REPAID.
THERE’S AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY GOING OUT HERE, I THINK
IT’S $377 BILLION, AND TREASURY
SECRETARY MNUCHIN SAYS LOOK, IF
WE RUN OUT OF THAT 377 BILLION,
WE’LL GO BACK TO CONGRESS, WE’LL
GET SOME MORE.
IT’S A RESCUE OPERATION AND IT
STARTS TODAY.
AINSLEY: BUT STUART REALLY
QUICKLY THAT NUMBER WE SEE AT
THE BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN DOES
THAT INCLUDE THE PEOPLE LAID OFF
THAT WILL COME BACK TO WORK ONCE
THIS IS ALL OVER?
STUART: YOU MEAN THE 701,000?
AINSLEY: UH-HUH, YES.
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
GET THEIR JOBS BACK.
STUART: WE DON’T KNOW THAT.
I SUSPECT THEY WILL.
AINSLEY: WELL IF YOU USE THAT
GRANT MONEY, THE ONLY WAY TO USE
THAT GRANT MONEY IS IF YOU GIVE
THEM THEIR JOBS BACK, SO ALL
THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES, THEY’RE
GOING TO HAVE TO PAY THOSE LOANS
BACK IF THEY DON’T REHIRE SO OF
COURSE THEY ARE GOING TO REHIRE,
YOU’D THINK.
STUART: LOOK THERE IS SOME
CONFUSION HERE.
THERE IS SOME CONFUSION HERE.
YOU’RE A SMALL BUSINESS OPERATOR
, YOU’RE IN DEEP TROUBLE
, YOU GO TO THE BANK
TODAY AND YOU SAY LOOK, HERE IS
MY PAYROLL FOR THE LAST EIGHT
WEEKS.
THEY WILL GIVE YOU THAT MONEY AS
A GRANT IF YOU DON’T LAY PEOPLE
OFF.
THEY WILL GIVE IT TO YOU AS A
LOAN, IF YOU DO LAY PEOPLE OFF
AND YOU’VE GOT TO REPAY THAT
LOAN, SO LET’S NOT GET ANY
CONFUSION HERE.
I DON’T KNOW WHOSE INCLUDED IN
WHICH NUMBER BUT THE RESCUE
OPERATION STARTS TODAY AND IT’S
A BIG OPERATION.
BRIAN:  THERE MIGHT BE ANOTHER.
THANKS STUART VARNEY.
WE’LL WATCH YOU ON FBN FROM 9:00